ابو عمرا ماذا عن وسط القطاع كيف يبدو
المشهد القطاع يتعرض لغارات جويه
اسرائيليه خلال الساعات الماضيه وبشكل
مكثف كان اخر هذه الغارات على مدينه دير
البلح وبالتحديد على منزل لعائله ابو نصير
حيث استشهد ما يقارب من الثلاثه فلسطينيين
وصلوا هنا الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلحه وما زال المواطنين والطواقم الطبيه
تعمل في المستشفى وبحسب ذوي ال العائله
عائله ابوسير يتحدثون عن ما يقارب من
العشره ما زالوا تحت انقاذ البنايه التي
تم تدميرها من قبل الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه والتي قصفت المنزل بدون سابق
انذار سبق هذه الغاره غارات اخرى ايضا على
دير البلح وايضا على وسط القطاع وبالتحديد
على منطقه مخيم النصيرات وهذا الامر ادى
الى وقوع اصابات وشهداء في هذه الغارات
اما منزل عائله صلاح في وسط مدينه دير
البلح والذي تعرض لغار ولقصر جوي من
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه وبصو ثقيله
لم ينفجر احد الصواريخ بداخل هذا المنزل
وكادت ان تكون هناك مجزره كبيره لان بداخل
هذا المنزل ما يقارب من ال 70 شخص من
النازحين ومن سكان المنزل الاصليين ولكن
رعايه لا تدخلت دون وقوع مجزره كبيره لان
الصاروخ الذي سقط من الطائرات الحربيه وهو
من الصواريخ الكبيره والثقيله لم ينفجر
بداخل هذا المنزل بخصوص ايضا الوضع
الانساني المتفاقم والذي ما زال تداعيات
المنخفض الجوي موجوده هنا في دير البلح
وعندما نتحدث عن دير البلح نتحدث عن اعداد
كبيره جدا من النازحين الذين وصلوا الى
هذه المدينه وتحولت مدينه دير بلح الى
كتله بشريه كبيره في هذا الوقت وحسب
هنا المختصين في دير البلح يتحدثون عن ما
يقارب من ال 400 ال الى نصف مليون مواطن
مازال متواجد في دير البلاح خلال الساعتين
الاخيرتين القوات الاسرائيليه اجبرت
مواطنين من منطقه تل الهواء على النزوح
قصرا
وبشكل قوي جدا وتحت تهديد السلاح وهذا
الامر ما تحدث به الم المواطنين الذين
وصلوا الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى هنا يحملون
اطفال ومعهم نساء وشيوخ كبار في السن
قالوا بان القوات
الاسرائيليه قامت ب يعني تفتيش منازلهم
والدخول اليها في منطقه تل الهواء واجبرته
على سلوك شارع البحر وصولا الى مدينه دير
بلح خلال الساعه الاخيره وقالوا بان الوضع
في منطقه تل الهواء صعب للغايه القوات
الاسرائيليه قامت باعتقال عدد من
الفلسطينيين هناك واجبرت النساء والاطفال
على سلوك شارع الرشيد البحر وصولا الى
مدينه ديرب بلح تحت هذه الظروف الانسانيه
الصعبه